last night I decided to turn on the TV
for a few minutes I basically don't
watch news shows or political shows I've
talked about this before I've always got
like some Netflix shows that I'm
watching and yesterday I watched what
did I watch I watched an episode of
hostages great Israeli show finished
watching that an episode of that with my
girlfriend and I said let's just see
what's happening in the news right like
what's happening on Fox News what's
happening on MSNBC what's happening on
CNN I turn to CNN which by and large has
been doing a mix of good reporting on
the Trump administration combined with
some salacious stuff that's less
relevant certainly a much better option
than Fox News for sure and I see
Anderson Cooper who recently interviewed
stormy Daniels on 60 minutes sitting at
his news desk with legal analyst Jeffrey
Toobin Michael avenatti who's the lawyer
for adult film actress stormy Daniels as
well as the lawyer for Trump's lawyer so
Trump has a lawyer Michael Cohen Michael
Cohen is in such hot water now as a
result of the stormy Daniels thing and
the non-disclosures that he has retained
a lawyer named David Schwartz as I told
you before Trump's lawyer has not lawyer
DUP here because of the trouble that
that he believes Trump is in he's
lawyered up because he potentially is in
trouble tells us how bad things were
going this was one of the most
embarrassing and pointless nearly
half-hour segments that I have ever seen
on corporate media to lawyers yelling at
each other the way they might do 30
seconds before turning to fisticuffs in
a bar right Michael Cohen's lawyer David
Schwartz is on the most fundamental
level a complete and total embarrassment
his mere presence on the network is
shameful stormy Daniels attorney Michael
avenatti he's known as this really savvy
legal operator he completely embarrassed
himself with his behavior stooping to
the same level as David Schwartz making
fun of Schwartz's weight at one point
how does it count as sort of legal
exploration of the merits of a case to
ridicule the fact that the other lawyer
is heavy right I mean that it is
absolute and total embarrassment and I
guess Anderson Cooper and Jeffrey Toobin
did what they could to kind of
control the situation but CNN should
certainly be embarrassed about this as
well I'm gonna play only a few clips for
you here it's just some random stuff
it's all like this nearly a half hours
worth take a look what's the first thing
that you think of I got to go to my
Pilates class that's the very first
thing that I think of when someone comes
up to me and threatens me with my
daughter anyone who has a daughter knows
you go right to the police it's
completely I'm sure she didn't go to the
police because she was scared and she
walked into the right that's where you
go to to get to the notion that he's
saying that it's defamatory power
lawsuit look about the letter yes oh
wait a minute last time you didn't let
me talk this time I'm like well this
time you are gonna let me talk otherwise
we're gonna have to get the
defibrillator out for you and I'm
conservative
almost believe me please go for right
yeah the American people saw last night
I think that's also kind of a fat joke
right like is it cuz the guy so heavy
that if he keeps talking he might need
to be defibrillated at her I don't even
know a half hour of this stuff here's
just another random sampling from later
on in the program she sat in an
interview for two hours or there abouts
and she faced the tough questions and
she answered them and the American
people saw those answers saw how she
answered the questions and I think 90%
of America 90% are you saying that it
was Michael Kohn who was at in Las Vegas
by the Pilates place are you saying it
was him personally course it wasn't Mike
okay you said that reason why God gave
you two ears and one mouth
arguments being made right I these are
two lawyers I would hire right away and
it's very easy to say it's one person
instigating here these are attorneys
representing people who couldn't be more
in the public eye and they go on
national media and this is how they
comport themselves on national
television here's just another few
seconds of this nonsense can I just talk
about the Muller to talk about the some
some fantasy
indictment you don't know what you have
no idea what you're talking about
interrupting you laughing with my body
just beat them alright can I speak you
know exactly what can I do
can I just raise that in just one more
clip here and this is sort of the
epitome of the entire thing let's talk
about Michael Cohen what kind of man
this is this is the kind of guy who
claimed in connection with that story
that there's no such thing as spousal
rape this is a legal genius right right
completely false the guy doesn't even
know the law he's a thug your friend is
a million dollars you see anyone by the
way so thought he was your dude your lie
detector test so okay no galvanic skin
response
is an utter embarrassment as far as the
substance the only substance came from
really specific questions from CNN legal
analyst Jeffrey Toobin and it exposed
that Cohen's attorney really doesn't
have good answers to a whole host of
questions but it doesn't matter because
the entire thing was just an
embarrassment who at CNN thinks this is
a good idea how is it responsible
counsel and forget about Schwartz right
Schwartz is there merely to muddle the
water that's all he wants to do because
Michael Cohen is not in a good position
but stormy Daniels and her attorney
presumably are there to make her seem
more credible to explain the legal
underpinnings of what's going on here
what is the upside for avenatti to
appear in a setting like this and to be
completely unable to control himself
it is pathetic and embarrassing every
step of the way and this is where I go
off a to to the point where I say is
this just all we can expect from a
network like this because they've done
some good stuff yeah should Anderson
Cooper have done a better job at
facilitating that debate or did he just
let it go because it's good television
after all is it though I mean the thing
is I don't know that it is actually good
because when you've got four people
talking at once it almost doesn't matter
who it is or what they're saying it just
doesn't work
and I I get to my bottom line on this
story which is I think that this is a
legitimate story not because Trump had
sex with someone but because the payoff
might have been illegal because of the
concerning pattern of lies and
manipulation of women all of that stuff
but we're not dealing with any of the
real substance when it's for people
talking over each other for a half hour
and acting literally like schoolchildren
one of the worst moments I've seen on
CNN in a very very long time the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad